people get raped because there's a
rapist is what I usually say for people
to assume that kind of thing really hard
to do it instead of did she say no
did you ask we're in the midst of this
perfect storm the stakes are very high
[Music]
drinking risk-taking and being away from
home for the first time a typical
student experience but it's also why
these young people are especially
vulnerable to sexual assault and why
consent is not as straightforward as it
should be and then the next day you're
like well we're in Ohio home to a large
student population to find out more
about what some researchers have
described as an epidemic of sexual
violence on America's campuses people we
speak to tell us the me2 movement hasn't
had enough impact on attitudes and
behavior
they're trying to grab you they're
trying to take you home I've had friends
that wake up the next morning and like
they remember saying if they said like
have sex with someone and they woke up
with like no clothes on
[Music]
everyone seems to know the ground rules
of sexual contact are changing and a few
young men admit they feel worried about
getting it wrong what if the next
morning after I meet a girl she regrets
it and then I become one of those people
that's locked up for something that I
thought was okay when it really wasn't
luckily I was with a really good group
of friends that took me home immediately
amid the shifting landscape these
students highlight how much work is
still to be done just like off the top
of my head I can things like ten
different women who I know like within
my friend group who have experienced
some form of sexual assault it's hard to
measure but one estimate suggests that
as many as one in four will be subjected
to a serious sexual assault before they
graduate Briana Colton is one of them I
personally like have been affected and
didn't report it so like I'm sure that
there are plenty of other women who
haven't so that statistic might even be
generous can I ask you why you didn't
report
um just like the stigma though what were
you wearing and like that particularly I
was wearing like a lower cut shirt I had
been drinking like not an excessive
amount but I had I was for sure drunk
like on the night that happened
I only remember like bits and pieces so
it's also then you start to question
like maybe I did consent initially and
then like there was like lost in
translation or you know it's their word
versus yours at that point so people get
raped because there's a rapist is what I
usually say Tara Purdy works at the
sexual violence crisis clinic that
covers several of the big universities
in Ohio
she says that campus culture can
reinforce the damaging idea that young
women are somehow to blame for being
vulnerable we don't ask people who have
been mugged why were you at the ATM you
got out money so you must have been
asking for it but we do say to victims
of sexual assault well why were just
your skirt so short you know why were
you out at night walking alone just down
the road at Antioch College they've long
taken a radical approach to preventing
sexual offences here any touch requires
clear enthusiastic verbal permission
it's called affirmative consent at every
step of physical or sexual contact you
ask for consent so let's say I'm with
somebody and we're hanging out and let's
say I have a crush and I want to kiss
them I'll say can I kiss you or can I
touch you here kind of hold your hand
can I like touch your thigh can I is
this okay do you feel okay with this and
you actually do that most of the time
and people do it to you yes yes it makes
me feel like respected more at least my
personal space is being respected like
when I'm outside of Antioch and somebody
just comes up and past my shoulder like
I didn't ask for that like I really
appreciate when people you know they
they don't just assume that they can
come into your space what do you say to
people who say this is all a bit over
the top
you're legislating intimacy and it's
just not practical
I would say you've probably never tried
this before because it does take
practice the first time I really try to
ask people about what they like it was a
little awkward you know you're not used
to asking if you can kiss someone or
asking if you can touch someone I think
the main reason is that especially in
the United States you're taught that sex
isn't something you should be talking
about or even especially as a woman I
feel like you're not supposed to talk
about sex you're not supposed to want
sex and I think this policy really
breaks that down I want to know that
someone's into what I'm doing before I
do anything because that's not sexy
because if the other person is not into
it I'm not into it either so I think
it's it's even more erotic when you know
that your partner is engaging and you
know that they're into what's happening
it's been this way here since the early
90s when a group of female students
wrote a manifesto on consent in response
to a rape on campus in the university
archived they've kept a record of how
the Antioch rules as they were called
were mocked all over the world we were
just on a mission to change a policy it
was an ideological fight it was a fight
about ideas bethany Saltman was one of
the original authors to me it's so
obvious it's so not a big deal it's like
instead of did she say no
did you ask it's just you know it's just
a flip of the switch which so many great
ideas are nearly three decades later all
visitors to Antioch even the sky news
crew still have to sign a form saying
they'll comply with the policies
versions of these rules have now become
commonplace on campuses across the
country sparking fierce debate about
whether universities are going too far
in their scramble to solve the problem
even here they seem uncertain in this
document you say if anyone's consumed
any alcohol consent cannot be given
that's correct
so technically to students who have a
beer and then have sex are assaulting
one another if somebody files a
complaint there's an assault
there is there is room for an assault
there yes should those determinations be
being made that have those lifelong
effects on people by universities the
way the current law is written yes is it
right though I don't know I really know
andrew miltenberg has defended hundreds
of accused young men who find themselves
investigated by colleges whether or not
the police are involved I think it's a
very dangerous time to be a young man on
campus we're in the midst of this
perfect storm where to be accused of
some sort of sexual misconduct virtually
assures that you will be found
responsible it is absolutely positively
ruining people's lives beyond repair he
says his clients are trapped in a highly
politicized sham justice system with no
consistency at all between schools and
low standards of evidence often required
to make decisions if you are found
responsible whether or not you're
suspended or expelled there will be a
permanent record of disciplinary and in
many cases sexual misconduct on your
transcript and that transcript is a
prerequisite to any type of graduate
school and it's also a prerequisite for
most professional type jobs so the
stakes are very high this young man and
his mother who don't want to be
identified say the current climate on
campus means even an accusation is
enough to change everything the way that
the school has done this has literally
destroyed my life after a student
accused him of rape he was investigated
and cleared three times once by the
police and twice by the University he
says the college assumed he was guilty
and the process violated his civil
rights every time he walked down the
hall it's like Oh like that's me my name
and then yeah he's a very bit like
pointing and everything for people to
assume that kind of thing about me was
really
it's just really hard to deal with for
people to label me something like that
when it's completely against Who I am
it's really hard to like go on like that
but for others the system is failing
because it's not robust enough MS Alka
wits accused a man of rape and then
carried a mattress around campus in
protest at the subsequent complicated
drawn-out investigation the art-student
became the face of the campus survivors
movement and insists that for everyone's
sake the police shouldn't be the only
option survivors who were assaulted in
university part of why they would rather
their university handle it then the
police department is that often they
feel like the crime was committed
because the their attacker wasn't
educated on consent their young right
like what back in university we were all
young we recognize that we do stupid
things so many survivors are like I
really just wish he would like go
through an educational program and maybe
get suspended for a month and then like
learn there are around 20 million
students at colleges across America and
in a few weeks time they'll all return
to class around them swirls a heated
legal and political battle about the
limits and responsibilities of the
schools they attend for now colleges
await new permanent guidelines from the
government leaving an imperfect system
to deal with the crisis
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News